yeah demain soir à la salle gaveau à
paris concert au profit du château de
versailles madame giscard d'estaing et
le ministre de la culture jean philippe
lecat y assisteront au programme mozart
fauré ravel debussy
tout cela pour permettre de rénover
versailles et en particulier les salles
du château qui avait été endommagée par
un attentat
les amis de versailles prestige et
beauté de paris les amis de paris 16
trois associations organisent demain
salle gaveau un concert de musique
française interprétée par des musiciens
français au profit du château de
versailles
si chacun sait que les magnifiques
soieries broderie et tapisseries de la
chambre de la reine ont pu être
reconstitués grâce à des dons en grande
partie on connaît moins l'histoire du
salon des jeux du roi qui est en train
de retrouver par la générosité de
plusieurs donateurs
c'est élégant siège son décor de cristal
et c'est en quoi nous et il ya toujours
quelque chose à restaurer à versailles
en ce moment le plus gros souci reste
les dégâts causés dans les salles et la
galerie empire par le stupide attentats
de juin dernier
l'énorme trou provoqué par la
déflagration entre le rez-de-chaussée et
le premier étage est toujours béant la
remise en état des murs des meubles et
objets d'art et des grandes toiles
retraçant les étapes de l'épopée
napoléonienne et commencé mais demandera
encore bien des efforts sous la
présidence de madame valérie giscard
d'estaing demain soir donc salle gaveau
un gala pour que versailles retrouver
conserve son lustre et que les affreux
panneaux de bois qui avait d'elle encore
4 des portes fenêtres du château
disparaissent au plus vite